yo green hola todos entonces para hacer
un mega Dora y como pruebas norges
nozaki really owe me tampoco nada que no
area yo el mundo esta cambiado es hora
de que cambiamos nosotros a gente que se
encarga desta's cosas ahora podemos taco
you
hey youtubers is charlie finally some
good news some new international
spider-man footage just focusing more on
the villain team up so I'll explain
their backstories but it's also
Stanley's birthday today in honor there
is a new round of the spider-man give
away all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
what a coincidence that all this
spider-man Deadpool stuff is dropping on
stan lee's birthday there'll be plenty
of that going on today so this
international teaser just features the
Shocker a little bit more prominently so
I'll explain his backstory but typically
when they released these smaller clips
they just focus more on the action of
the film so just going on the little
footage that we've seen of him so far we
kind of see this story play out over the
course of the trailers so you see
spider-man getting his ass kicked by
shocker here around all these school
buses somewhere at his school presumably
he's wearing the hoodie so this looks
like it might be happening before
captain america civil war before he gets
that stark tech suit may be spider-man
barely crawls away or some help just
barely manages to get the upper hand but
then later we see spider-man in the
stark tech suit presumably later in the
timeline after Captain America Civil War
stopping the bank robbery and we see
someone using almost the exact same
technology to get that ATM so that might
be the shocker to so like he's slowly
coming back into spider man's life after
he has his new gear so it looks like
spider-man just has a much easier time
of taking him down but then we get that
Michael Keaton vulture line where he's
like times are changing time for us to
change too we see the Donald Glover
scene who is probably playing the
Prowler teaming up with the other
villains like the shocker so it seems
like the vulture is like slowly
assembling a villain team up but the big
rumor is is it's the tinkerer who helps
them with their technology and a lot of
this is based on Avengers shatori
invasion technology that's been left
over if you remember way back after the
first Avengers film they had that item
47 short where they had like there's two
regular people that were down and out on
their luck so they got a [ __ ] our gun
and they were going to use it to rob
banks just because they felt they had no
other options egg we should bail
Benny it's too late for that come on
Claire we will know we're doing I don't
you know if you do yes I do I really do
okay that they fell out of the sky into
our laps I mean to me that's a sign okay
what makes you so sure sign is pointing
in the right direction you make me sure
cuz you got it to work always said that
we deserve better right so I wait for
somebody to give us a chance time it
would took a chance for ourselves I hope
you're right
that also kind of reads like the
Shockers character from the comics so
that might have something to do with the
Shockers reason for teaming up with the
vulture and these other characters so in
the comics his name is Herman Schulz he
was this really brilliant inventor who
drops out of high school but he's still
I mean he's this really smart person but
he's kind of down and out on his luck so
he turned to crime to support himself
eventually gets his ass handed to him
thrown in prison in develops the Shocker
gauntlets starts committing even bigger
crimes you're going for bigger paydays
and starts bumping into spider-man more
taking on the Shocker persona shaki
shaki shaki Britta thought-out ended you
old son but you got more lives in the
bag of cash so he's really good at
cracking safes like we see the fake
Avengers doing here but he also has like
a relatively fluid morality like he is a
bad person doing bad things but he's not
completely evil so sometimes when he has
spider man at his mercy he'll let him go
like he won't kill him when he has the
chance because he's after some big score
he doesn't want to kill people he just
wants the money so very honor amongst
thieves type person that also might have
something to do with the vulture too
although based on the dialogue that
Michael Keaton has in all these trailers
he is hardcore do not come after me I
will kill everybody you love so he might
be the one that crosses the line like
you have all these other minor villains
like the Tinker the shocker the Prowler
teaming up with the vulture and they're
all in it because they like money but
not because they want to murder a whole
lot of people and that's usually where
your villain team-ups fall apart you
have someone who crosses the line and
then the rest just kind of bail on him
and leave him for the heroes to take
down so the way they're presenting
spider-man in this first movie is that
he's like still figuring things out he's
a pretty strong hero he has really
amazing powers he's an Avengers level
hero but his Tony Stark continues to
joke he still has a long ways to go let
the adults handle this just be a kid so
he is probably going to get his ass
handed to him by most of these villains
at least a couple times during the movie
before he finally takes them
down with a little bit of help from
Uncle Tony so a lot of trailers can be a
little misleading just remember that
even though the vulture is the big bad
of the film that doesn't mean that he's
going to be like a mustache twirling
villa I don't think Michael Keaton would
be playing a character if he were that
simple so in the comics the vulture yes
very bad person but he's totally screwed
over by his business partner he's
actually a fairly brilliant inventor in
his own right gets screwed over by his
business partner his only recourse is to
turn to crime to save the situation then
later you know after he's become the
vulture character wearing the flight
suit going up against spider-man
eventually we learn about his family
that he cares about deeply so he has
grandchildren his grandson has a
terminal illness in the only way he can
finance a cure for him is to commit
crimes he also kills a gang Lord to save
his nephew so he's not above crossing
the line when it comes to his family so
I mean that's really like where the hero
step in where it's like we all care
about our families but there's a line
that you don't cross like you don't
murder people in cold blood so it just
all comes back around to great power
great responsibility so you guys can let
me know let's talk more about the
villains of spider-man homecoming what
do you think is going to be the point at
which they team up in what do you think
is going to be the big point of
contention that causes them to fall
apart allowing Tony Stark and spider-man
to take them all down because it sounds
like the upgrades that they go through
through the course of the movie make
them this invincible bad guy team up at
least from spider man's perspective like
too hardcore for him to take on by
himself so something bad enough has to
happen for Tony to get up off his ass
and come help spider-man out like okay I
wasn't going to do this but now things
have gotten so bad that I need to put my
armor on and step in and given the Tony
causes as many problems as he solves it
sounds like the vulture is going to be
more than a match for him so something's
going to have to happen to cause this
villain team up to fall apart usually
it's the idea that none of the villains
or most of the villains don't care about
each other no honor amongst thieves
thing like usually you know one person
in the group has no honor in the rest of
them abandoned him so that sounds like
that's going to be the vulture character
but like I said because it's stan lee's
birthday today they announced some
special Deadpool Wolverine movie stuff
going on so I'll do a video for that
next that might not post till tomorrow
morning but there's going to be all
kinds of Wolverine Deadpool stuff
happening early in the year so 2017
starting it off right it's going to be
awesome so I will say congratulations to
this week's spider-man giveaway winner a
Ryan you win a twenty-dollar amazon gift
card be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so we can get
your contact details there is a new
round of the giveaway that starts now
I'll announce the winner when I post
that Wolverine Deadpool video so again I
2017 is going to be so awesome I like to
go into it feeling very optimistic about
all the stuff that's coming especially
given all the sad stuff that's happened
late in this year what you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to watch
the longer spider-man trailers and you
can click here for a brand new arrow
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you